[Applause]
this notebook is mr. know-it-all the
tarnish wisdom of a filth elder john
waters everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you look fantastic you always look
the same well I'm trying to be as
disreputable as always you are I gotta
tell you you're a hero of mine because
what are you 73 now yep yeah okay and
you know I'm always on this show they
got in the case it's too young for that
you're still alive
actually sort of an idea but um but you
know I'm always saying you know ageism
it's you don't judge people on their age
people are 95 and still work in the
fields in some places and you you just
did acid for the first time not like
first time well in a long time are you
kidding last time you were here you were
just hitchhiked across the country
that's true but when I was 66 when I did
that alone right but but I hadn't done
it in 50 years and I thought I had a
great time then so I decided my new
stunt for the book was to take acid at
70 with Ming stole my friend that's been
for 50 years poor and we did explore I
had such nostalgia remembering that Lam
in your throat what it feels like right
before you blast off and never trip I
did but I didn't have phlegm oh and I
don't I'm not telling young people to
take acid you have your [ __ ] micro
doses you know but take it right if
taking the whole four people you know
your love memories of it take it today
nobody can say it's dementia you're
tripping right
what that way you're always fit as a
fiddle you never canceled the show right
no I never have you know I've done it
with a flu old school but do you know
how to do it when you have to time it
wiping your nose with laughs the whole
time you know when you're doing a comedy
show it's all you seem to have trouble
with phlegm everything comes down to
that no I but I know I did mm
politically incorrect yeah I missed when
I was on your circle you have 500 of
these never never missed a stand-up show
except with them in the plane couldn't
get there old school yeah I know yeah
show must go on yeah yeah but it's
interesting in your book you say there's
no downside to fame no the only bad
thing that ever happened once I had a
kidney stone which is the most horrible
thing and so to go to the doctors and be
in the waiting room they say Hayes Joe
waters what's the matter with you or
worse
whose daughter you're sitting there said
but you know what if you weren't famous
you wouldn't have gotten the appointment
in the first place yeah that's true not
bad people come over and say I hate to
interrupt when you're eating I say no
you don't you just did but you paid for
this dinner yeah that's in this family I
mean I can go well you're not right
Michael Jack's no but that's the point
of show business is demit work so hard
so you can never go out yeah that's the
friend I know I just not go hide
business right right so you're in a
weird way you know you are respectable
now I want to try not to be no no but
they say if you it's like you know they
can't get rid of what's the saying but
there's like old buildings and [ __ ] or
old [ __ ] and buildings or something
becomes respectable over it's done and
you're an old [ __ ] let's yeah
I try to keep up by saying things like I
think stormy Daniels lawyer is really
handsome and will do well in jail saying
that basically I try to be gaily
incorrect and say yeah everything they
say against us is true we do recruit
there's one you've got such a great
thing going on because everybody else in
show business they go back in time and
look at what people did in the past and
oh that's not politically correct that's
not good enough today if they could find
things and friends they're fat-shaming
in their home well the thing is thank
you you were always trying you were
aggressively and politically correct you
are weirdly because I'm never I make fun
of things I love and so I'm not
mean-spirited you know and what we have
to do in this next election is not I get
why the Trump people like him because we
hate him but we have to make our
opponents not feel stupid which what we
do we may have to make them feel smart
that they're going to change and that's
the difference Oh trick yeah and we'll
be able to trick them because they're
stupid
I mean they should all have a meeting
all the Democratic candidates a secret
one and plot let's pick two because I
and all the rest quit now I'm gonna get
to that at the end I want to get you gay
matters I love your book you know and
that books are for wise people you know
you're wise it's fighting this open
society doesn't get the people get wiser
when they're old every other society has
figured this out well the only boy yeah
okay so like you were talking about your
younger days and their oven
you're still Robin style I'm sorry I
still live there yeah yeah what is I go
there in the summers my 5454 summer
there yeah what what is bear week well
bear week is overweight bear hairy gay
men but getting fatter I'm telling you
and I saw what I thought it was a hedge
but it was a person
and when we were tripping it was bear
week we didn't go out that's where the
winter bears are especially welcomed
well yeah babe a name every week they
have gay pilots we thought of that
analingus week you know that's coming
[Laughter]
sorry it's my job too big anniversary
this week yeah this month
Stonewall does that famous riot that
happened yeah people don't know there
was a gay bar in the village and one
that nobody went it was all like
hustlers and hookers yeah that's great
but whoever thought it was the same day
Judy Garland died
could there be that day a day that the
cops had busted this place and that
Olivia bar yeah she used to used to
browse gay folks and they would check
drag queens had to have on one pair of
men's clothes or they'd be arrested
oh so they wore jockey shorts under an
evening gown okay but but yeah and they
fought back for the first time for the
first race and you say this is because
Judy Garland had just I guess they were
feeling in a bad mood okay but I I hope
people buy your book well you know I
noticed this week with the malla report
we're talking about he had to like come
out and say read it because people don't
read anymore yeah I mean if your book
does fantastic it's not gonna do what
books used to do when people who wants
to read that because he didn't same
thing it's like watching the weather and
they say a 50/50 chance of rain what
always is maybe well maybe it won't but
I I dug up an old quote of yours you
said if you go home with someone and
they don't have books don't [ __ ] them
well
[Applause]
but I have an answer to that now if you
go home with somebody and they have
books in the bathroom don't [ __ ] up
either the only good thing about this we
don't have to move our bowels again so
let's let's talk about the presidential
race I tell you thinking
[Applause]
you